[Music]
you have 42 million Facebook friends
million yeah
and you use them to help you cast the
film meaning you'll say to them who do
you want to see me opposite and they
actually had a pretty good idea well
multiple times yeah they were the first
ones to suggest Dwayne Johnson and I
working together yes yeah without
without giving that six away that cameo
at the end was strictly from the
Facebook page they all said we had a
dream of seeing you guys work together
and that's where that cameo comes from
the dance so here's my question let's
say you're 42 million Facebook friends
told you for fast furious 7 we want to
see Conan as your partner no but you
knew deep down that would kill the
franchise me in the car with you no it's
too fast
slower slower
trying to get my seatbelt on the whole
time you couldn't listen to the neck you
can't listen to him ELISA they know it's
it's such a rare moment in Hollywood
where we're able to actually hear
feedback from the audience yeah and I
think it makes for a better movie what's
also interesting is your fans are very
devoted and the the art
on the internet that's devoted to you is
quite spectacular so much of it and and
and quite unusual some of it let's take
a look this is what the fans I like this
one
at Hannibal that's all the little Hamill
okay that's your eyes and an elephant
coming out okay this is just you with
baby lions yeah you know it happens
that's like a Tiger Beat pull out you
know that's what that there you go I
like that one actually I want this for
my room I just that's a poster that's
available now you can see that we know
interesting so many so many of those
pictures now have cats because I did
this photo shoot for prestige and I was
working with this live leopard that got
loose and they all wrangled the leopard
and then gave me the leash to hold that
is so crazy they wrangled the leopard
you didn't because you're an action star
people expect you in that situation to
tackle right and I was just on the wall
playing it cool like this yeah and then
they finally got this leopard and they
go just hold it and standing on top of
it and take your shirt off and what was
this for again
prestige Hong Kong yeah okay hey they do
me someone's playing a joke on you we're
doing a photo shoot take your shirt off
you know what's good you uh I have to
also want to comment you on your voice
you have I'm you have a very distinctive
and very cool voice I've always hated my
voice I can't stand it it's like hey
everybody you got an itch oh come on
look at the program and that's kept me
from the action films but you have that
great you have that great great voice
for action movies nice to be a
telemarketer is that yeah but I couldn't
be a talk show host I mean I don't have
anything about well I don't have enough
of that
you know calming voice why are you going
way up here I don't know what do you
mean oh I can never be a talk to us